hey everyone i'm lucy and joining me
today to discuss the recently revealed
marvel's guardians of the galaxy we've
got folks from marvel games and idos
montreal so let's go around the panel
we've got
senior narrative director mary did mall
hello
we have uh senior creative director
john francois duga and we also have
vp of creative of marvel games bill
roseman pew pew hello true believer
now we've got we've got quite the panel
to discuss this game so bill i'm going
to come to you first
why idose for guardians galaxy
marvel's built upon really bringing
together
the right creators with the characters
they love and and
letting the creators bring their voice
in their vision and telling
their story with the marvel characters
and that's the case here idols montreal
has uh the passion the knowledge
the the rock and roll uh dna
the humor to to create this the story
they're the perfect
they're the perfect collaborators to
bring them to life
and we can't wait for the players to get
their hands on the game
it's it's it's it's just freaking
delightful what what
what that's all we can hope for at
marvel is people who love the characters
as much as we do
to bring themselves to them and and
create something awesome
and i mean speaking of the characters
you obviously have this sort of
embarrassment of riches to choose from
when it comes to
marvel characters both uh you know the
famous faces that we've seen
uh for the last however many decades but
also you kind of have those more
niche villains and heroes to pull from
so mary where do you start when you
tackle a project like
guardians of the galaxy like you
obviously have the comics you've got the
movies but you're wanting to put your
own spin on things
where do you start well for us we really
start by diving into the resource
material so
obviously we've seen the movies and
loved them
and we then did a deep dive into the
comic books
and it was really fun to discover the
the the differences that between these
characters
in the different forms they took there's
always a common essence of who these
characters are but they were always a
little bit different and and realizing
that you kind of realize
okay now we get to put our stamp on
on this by discovering what we want to
bring as long as we're true to the
essence of you know star-lord the space
pirate
gamora the deadliest woman in the galaxy
and
you kind of just dive into the source
material and then you
let your imaginations go wild and you
work with bill
and his team to make sure that
everything you're putting forward
is still staying within that that
essence of the characters i was going to
say and i mean watching the presentation
it's immediately apparent just like the
characters you've nailed them but it's
also really
really funny what are the challenges of
making a game where you can hear those
lines over and over again
is the game still funny to you are you
still charmed by these moments between
all these characters
well i'll let uh villain and jf add to
it if they want to but
writing humor is one of the challenges
most challenging things
there is to do because you're right if
you're working on a project for a long
time you start hearing the same lines
over and over
and you start wondering are they funny
or not i think i worked with a group of
amazing writers who just
bounced off each other all the time and
going through the various stages of
seeing it on the paper then doing tts
and then going into the actual
voice actors it never ever got old and
there are still
jokes that today just make me laugh out
loud when we started that project she
she was very nervous because she was
like i don't know how to write
humor and whatnot but with the team she
she pulled together
they really managed to to to pull this
off and to be honest with you
to this day there are some scenes that
we're still
laughing out loud and everything and we
go like
okay if we still enjoy it we we feel
like that
there there's something there that will
be really um
fresh for for players and will be uh
really like
bill said delightful and you know it's
like it's like your favorite
uh comedy you can watch a movie over and
over and if it makes you laugh
it'll still make you laugh so um
yeah they just they they in addition to
the rock and roll
that's the one thing that the team
really got was
um the game is fun and it's funny
and that's what you expect from
guardians you expect that that marvel
blend of
drama and intensity and then someone
cracks a joke
and that's that's part of the the the
marvel magic and they
they nailed it i mean speaking of
intensity uh jean francois i'm very
interested to know
what the the leap was like everyone
obviously knows of idols montreal has
kind of been the deus ex studio
and you and mary have both worked on
deus ex what was the leap like for you
to create something that's so high i
mean
deus ex has its moments of high octane
gameplay but you know you you think of
adam jensen as like
skulking in the shadows whereas with
marvel's guardians of the galaxy
it's the completely other end of the
spectrum you
are firing your blasters you're jumping
all over the place but you're also kind
of micromanaging
the rest of the guardians in a way so
what was the leap like to implementing
that
working on the previous games like you
mentioned you you go and read like
philosophy
and when you start to work on guardians
of the galaxy you go bungee jumping
and that's the kind of link in your head
that
you have to to to go for
it it was for us it was truly exciting
because
anything like when we were working on
desks or
or past titles uh in our carriers like
one of the first thing that goes through
my mind when i'm uh
presented a potential project is can i
fall in love with this
yes or no and if i can fall in love with
it and if i feel like the material
there's so much richness to be
to be explored then i will get excited
and i would say on top of that
is so that was it's kind of the the
first step
and early on uh when we knew that this
was to to happen uh we flew to ellie and
meet
bill and his team and everything and we
had a great discussion that lasted for
probably a couple of hours
because like any collaboration until you
you're together
you never know what their intentions are
what is your sandbox and
and things like that and very early on
uh we discovered that uh bill and his
team at marvel games like that they were
fully excited they said we brought you
on board for
what you're able to do not for what us
we are we want you to
to bring your own flavor into our own
identity
and and that was exciting because we we
saw that we
we had the quite some freedom and um
and to test that because like we have
this initial meeting right and we
exchanged those those
those wishes and we started to work and
brainstorm in montreal and the first
iterations
of the characters that we did like we
said we'll put it to
11 and we'll push those characters and
bill and his team
they flew to montreal and we set them on
our couch
and maybe it was a few seconds but for
me it lasted minutes in my head like
bill was like this
in my head i was like oh my god we're
dying they're going to kill us and
everything
but no actually what we did was too much
but we fully appreciated that we were
trying to bring something to the table
and after that we just worked together
to refine to the looks
that you're you're you're seeing today
so it's it's quite exciting
for for us because sometimes people
speak but
do they mean what they say and on both
ends i think we
we we match that and we were very happy
with that and it was quite a journey
and you're right jeff if i can just jump
on and say throughout marvel's history
that's the secret you know when you when
you look at the history of marvel comics
for example
there are famous runs that readers love
and you say
oh you know uh you say frank miller's
daredevil
walt simonsen's thor you know john burns
run
on on fantastic four it's it's yes
they're marvel characters but
when the creators come and they have a
vision and they bring themselves to the
character and they
they present the character in a new
fresh way that's revolutionary and
interesting
we love that so that that's that that's
our philosophy
and we want them to bring themselves and
and do
their versions it's their vision and
their versions of the guardians
but still what just said about bungee
jumping
jf and and mary they bungee jump see
those books right behind mary those
marvelous books
they jumped into those
they did and they came back and
presented their vision and their story
and you'll see in the game it is just
packed
with i won't even call them easter eggs
they're they're building blocks they're
marvel dna
characters locations moments images
sounds it all comes organically and
authentically
from the source material and it's it's a
love letter
to love letter to the characters that is
that is authentic and true to the
history but still fresh and new
in creating creating a a modern
experience
no higher praise than that uh i was
gonna ask
obviously you're playing through the
game of star-lord but you have the group
to think of you have those dynamics i
noticed you know there's a point in the
gameplay where drax
throws rocket over over some sort of
gorge and there's this you know
kind of devastating rocket is mad at you
because you did this
um what's it like sort of balancing
those group dynamics
you know making sure that everyone gets
their fair say everyone gets
the right amount of screen time um but
without it becoming overbearing because
you know
too many cooks too many too many
guardians yelling at you to do the right
thing
i suppose how do you keep how do you
keep that balanced well
i think the way we do it is you start
with you know well we start i start
obviously with the story and we know
that we're writing an ensemble storyline
because
yes star-lord is a central character and
everything that happens in the game
is is through his eyes he's at the
center of every decision that has to be
made
and he's really experiencing the other
characters
um these unique wild you know
misfits who have very strong
personalities of their own and so
finding the balance between making sure
that
all of those characters have their their
screen time have their uh
moments together you kind of just look
at it
through the eyes of star-lord and you
and you start it all starts kind of
falling into place at least that's how
it felt for me ensuring that every
character has their own moments
their own arcs and yet because you're
star-lord at the center you're
controlling it and you get to make the
choices
in those moments to talk to various
characters or to
chime in on their conversations and they
go in different ways as a result
and all of it just comes into this great
infused
center focus on you are star-lord and
you are hanging out with these amazing
characters
and having really really deep meaningful
yet
funny conversations with them along with
all the gameplay and the battles and and
the stuff that you're
you're um leading them through just to
say uh to complete with uh
uh with what mary just said from a story
perspective but also from
an experienced perspective like being
star-lord like this fantasy of being
one of the guardians and being
surrounded by camera drugs groot and
rocket
almost at any given time like it was
also in game play the same thing like
creating scenarios in which like the
different characters would have
uh key roles to play or the way you play
in the decisions you make
can affect them and how they're going to
react to certain events and will force
you to
to re-adapt afterwards and that was also
a central piece of the experience that
we were figuring out for the last few
years
awesome and i was going to ask because i
mean first of all the game is coming out
way sooner than i assumed like i mean i
suppose
maybe i'm just used to the you know
we'll show it at e3 and you'll get it
next year so it's coming out october
26th um single player um
coming out for kind of current gen and
uh last gen two so i think yes
you know you've obviously been working
on this game for such a long amount of
time uh
i've got to ask is it kind of a
self-contained story is it the beginning
of you know hopefully way more guardians
uh stories to come i can see an eyebrow
twitching there bill
um but what i mean what what's the
future you're hoping that this is gonna
be the next
big huge franchise from idols i'll i'll
say this in in true
marvel fashion um i just montreal
has presented an experience that if
you're a huge marvel fan
or a huge guardians fan you're going to
really love
the deep dive if you're if you're new to
the guardians
it's just going to be really fun and an
awesome experience because they're so
good
at at what they do you don't need to
know anything going into it
everything is laid out everything is
introduced you understand
all the relationships uh uh and who
everyone is
it is a i would say it is a complete
story
self-contained adventure but you know
however in true marvel style
it also sets up some awesome story
threads so
who can say what the future will hold
but uh you're gonna get a full
complete uh experience when you play
this game
and like i said it's out in october so
one final quick question before we go
there's a lot of licensed music in this
and obviously music is a huge part of
the
guardians is that going to come out as a
soundtrack because already
you've got holding out for hero you've
got bad reputation you've got me on
board already
i mean how many more how many more
bangers are on that soundtrack i have to
ask
and what was the process like in
choosing them just very quickly
yeah uh i i think one of the the main
things like bill was seeing earlier on
uh the misfits are the misfits the
guardians are kind of
rock and roll misfits and yeah and peter
is a kid from
uh earth and he grew up in the 80s and
a lot of the pop culture back in that
time like it's what influenced him and
when he was a
kidnap and was taken in the cosmic
universe and everything his point of
reference
is still back in the 80s and everything
so
uh we started with our audio director
and with marvel and
talk about like the songs that we would
love to have we
we build a list and and and we try to be
eclectic to really capture the vibe like
not just go
into pop or just in rock and roll like
we mix
a lot of these things uh together to try
to have
a broad scope of like peter all the
things he
loved back then and he brought him with
him uh
in in the guardians of the galaxy uh
world that we we
created and so so it was a
a very fun process or just going back to
the memory lane you know sometimes
you're
you're at home at night and you just go
through the old video clips of mtv and
things like that and you go
oh yeah that was good and after that it
was also a question
that the lyrics needed to speak to the
the events of the game like
it's not just the song for for the
effect of the song it needs also to
speak to
to the emotional uh curves that that
we're
exploring and today i'm not going to go
that much in detail but you have seen is
a teaser
in the in the presentation today where
the music will play a role in gameplay
and we call it the huddle
and when you're in on the battlefield
and you're you're you're
you're you're fighting enemies uh at
some point
like you have a token that builds up
that at some point you can use
and that is based on some of the songs
that peter note
tried to pump his team so we'll talk
about it a little bit more in detail
uh down the road but but we wanted to
infuse the music
also into the the gameplay experience
and like
bill uh teases is that there's more to
the music that we're not talking today
that will come
wonderful well bill jean francois and
mary thank you
so much for joining me today and like i
said marvel's guardians of the galaxy is
out october 26th and for more from this
year's e3 and of course play for all
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot
you